[Music]  are you asking me to the school dance  on my way i think is the perfect song  the perfect theme for cat and charlie  the nuances of it are  [Music]  pointing me beautiful just taking me  home it's about always remembering where  she's from and coming into her own not  just as a person  in relationships but also as an artist  and growing because those kind of things  go hand in hand  i don't understand why i was going  through all of these trials and  tribulations and heartbreaks and all of  these things  but now it makes sense because i met you  now it makes sense because i have you  now it makes sense because of us we kind  of work to help complete the story  [Music]  [Music]  you